the EU is investing 8.8 billion euro in  the Youth Employment initiative until  2020 to help young people access  education and find a job members are to  discuss how these programs are carried  out how do you prevent the financial  system being used to fund criminal  activities Parliament will look at ways  to tackle the funding of crime such as  greater transparency and limits on the  amount of cash that can be carried  around members are to discuss the  humanitarian situation in Libya after  reports showing African migrants been  sold into slavery sparked an  international outcry women are often  more vulnerable to climate change than  men because of unequal access to  resources job opportunities and land  rights Parliament is exploring ways to  help them people with disabilities often  don't enjoy equal representation and  opportunities in the workplace members  are looking at an eu-wide strategy to  tackle issues such as gender equality  poverty and discrimination